هو زعيم لتحالف يضم سته احزاب مختلفه هو
يرتبط بقوه الطاوله السداسيه اي ان هذه
الطاوله صنعت كمالك
يوجد ايجابيه في هذه النقطه
امام زعيم المعارضه اسابيع قليله فقط
ليثبت انه ند لاردوغان لذا عليه تقديم
اوراق اعتماد قويه للشارع الذي يتطلع لحل
مشاكل استعصت على حكومه الرئيس الحالي رجب
طيب اردوغان وفي مقدمتها الازمه
الاقتصاديه
بالطبع المشاكل التي ستواجهك الجدار اوغلو
عديده منها تجديد نظام الحكم والثانيه هي
مشكله تركيا الكبيره وهي المشكله
الاقتصاديه كما تعلمون تركيا تتاثر متعدده
سنوات بالمشاكل التي تعصف بالعالم يمكننا
الحديث عن مشكله اقتصاديه كبيره لاجل ذلك
يجب القيام بشيء اتجاهها
ايضا من الملفات التي يتعين على كلجدار
اوغلو تقديم حلول لها هي الاثار الكارثيه
التي خلفها الزلزال المدمر في السادس من
فبراير الماضي
يقلل كثيرون من ازمه تحالف الامه المعارض
التي سبقت اختيار المرشح المشترك ويرى
هؤلاء ان معارضي اردوغان سيقبلون باي
شخصيه تنافس الرئيس الحالي لكن في المقابل
هناك وجهه نظر اخرى تعتقد ان كلجدار اوكلو
لن يكون بكفاءه اردوغان فضلا عن كونه لا
يحظى بقبول كبير في الشارع كرسي بلديه
اسطنبول وانقره زيدان زنجلو العربيه
اسطنبول